imaginez que l'on prie le carrefour
médicis de son jet d'eau que l'on
arrache à la rue soufflot sont chères
panthéon
que resterait-il du quartier latin les
cafés par dizaines ils se pressent
s'entassent les uns contre les autres
après s'être paré sans pudeur de noms
prestigieux ils ouvrent tout grand leurs
bras aux étudiants de paris
[Musique]
l'heure de pointe se situe entre midi et
deux heures
et l'affluence est telle que l'on se
demande ce qu'il adviendrait de tous ces
étudiants
s'il n'y avait pas de café pour les
recevoir ne croyez surtout pas que ces
jeunes gens viennent ici pour boire mais
il faut bien payer sa place comme dans
tous les pays acp
qu'est ce que vous buvez mademoiselle
quand vous venez au café à du café en
café le général
moi je bois d'express souvent un café
crème pourquoi café crème bien c'est
parce que c'est moins cher
oui on voit vous mademoiselle moi j'ai
fait mes études pour apprendre le
français
et c'est à paris je suis depuis janvier
suit des cours à la seconde et de quel
pays venez vous aussi dans le monde
vous êtes allemande et et vous monsieur
je suis malgache et jeu terminant
seulement mes études en physique
nucléaire
est ce que dans votre pays en allemagne
alors moi vous habitez oui est ce qu'il
ya des cafés comme à paris oh non vous
savez c'est tout à fait différent un
offre il y à des cafés plus élégant et
chic c'est à dire pour les étudiants on
trouve pas d'étudiants trouvent les
vielles dames dimanche la tarte et les
étudiants il y a une chose spéciale sa
péniche pas c'est à dire on boit du lait
une mixte chèques et des choses comme ça
là on trouve des étudiants mais pas dans
les cafés
qu'est-ce que vous dépenser beaucoup
d'argent pour venir au café au oui oui
oui oui le point consacré un petit
budget pour le cap et les cigarettes
venez vous seul au café j'y vais seul
mais je suis sûr de rencontrer des amis
quand je suis ce que je rencontre pas
d'amis je m'en vais dans quelques
minutes parce que je ne pas rester seul
dans un café pourquoi
vous savez la jeune fille celle de
l'ancien café il ya trop de gens qui
regardent et moi je suis timide je ne
peux pas rester seul dans un café
j'avais je vois mon café à mehdi je mens
je sais mais je sais pas ce que je peux
pas manger toujours dans un restaurant
ça coûte trop cher je bois mon café mon
service et s'il ya quelqu'un pas d'amis
je m'en vais tout de suite vous êtes
vous rencontrés connu tous les deux
oui a longtemps que j'avais mais où on
my own quoi j'étais une semaine c'est à
paris j'étais tout ça je connaissais
personne
j'étais moyen j'avais départ était avec
un ami
regardez toujours gtc j'étais content de
trouver quelqu'un pour râler quand vous
retournerez en allemagne est-ce que vous
garderez à un souvenir spécial pour les
cafés du quartier latin
oui ça c'est sûr vraiment ça me manquera
beaucoup
j'ai fait des études de sciences
économiques
les études de mathématiques une licence
de matinée
vous êtes je crois à normale sup we are
contenait personne normale supérieure
des fonds de fonds et autrement dit vous
êtes un peu éloigné de paris
j'habite en banlieue mais je prends tous
mes cours à la faculté de paris à la
sorbonne ya la nouvelle faculté de
sciences à la halle aux vins autrement
dit vous avez peut-être temps mort nous
avons beaucoup de temps morts dans la
journée
c'est pour ça que nous occupons souvent
à venir au café mais pourquoi
n'allez-vous pas dans une bibliothèque
bibliothèque je n'aime pas c'est froid
c'est trop
obstacle
vous important bien fait
difficile à bio
vampires alors toi seul mais entouré de
personnes et c'est beaucoup plus vivant
ou par exemple qu'une
bio tech c'est moins sûr fait que ma
peau c'est moi qu'on passait est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est journée dans un
café ça peut ajouter quelque chose à la
formation
oh je crois
oui mais bon ça
cela nous apprend à ne pas nous prendre
au sérieux est-ce qu'on va tellement de
gens dans les caf extrêmement sérieux
que ça nous fait une bourde philosophie
de dispagne builder est ce la seule
raison
et
on rencontre des gens nombreuses
personnes différentes et
cela nous arrange pour la vie lorsque
vous êtes au café ce que vous souhaitez
rencontrer des gens d'un autre milieu
j'aime les parents rencontrés mais c'est
difficile ça l'est toujours dans les
cafés que prépare les étudiants n'ont
même quand je vais dans un quartier
différent ce sont les gens qui sont de
mon milieu avec lequel je crois beaucoup
d'étudiants essaie de parler de leur
travail
donc ces seniors d empêcher bien sûr et
on essaie de faire parler d'autre chose
alors ça commence par le temps ensuite
de la conversation dévie on en arrive
aux au livre qu'on lit
spectacle de convoi aux promenades qu'on
fait
c'est assez varié où on joue on fait des
jeux de quelques fois des jeux de
société vous êtes beaucoup contre le
café à tikrit où l'on est sûr de
rencontrer des amis non je ne sais pas
cela
j'aime tous les cafés l'insolite et je
n'aime pas avoir vu thi l'habitude dans
un calcul non c'est là que déjà
bourgeois bonne arrivée je préfère me
promener
quelque chose attendre que touchante
c'est pas une petite aventure que la
chaque fois
plus dans un quartier une petite
histoire nouvelle il ya une espèce de
griserie à se mettre dans la foule et ça
fait un peu tourner la tête c'est pas
désagréable
ainsi dans ce grand café où l'on vient
tuer le temps l'insolite aventure ouvre
des horizons que ken fermer les murs
épais les grandes écoles mais on ne
vient pas au café uniquement pour rêver
certains étudiants y travaillent est il
possible ou non d'étudier au milieu du
bruit et de la foule cette question nous
l'avons posée aux clients du rouquet le
café attitré des étudiants en médecine
de la nouvelle faculté france étudiants
en médecine dont profite qu'a fait
la plupart oui
vous travaillez quelques mots café
c'est dépend des caractères pourquoi
tous les pans les caractères boillon est
qu'il faut nous frayer
oui
ça vous paraît tout de même difficile
pour procéder à ce qui paraît impossible
de travailler oui ces défauts quelle
matière ça départir matière vous pensez
qu'on peut étudier la médecine au café
non
c'est un peu trop sérieux le droit le
droit
[Applaudissements]
mademoiselle vous arrivez à travailler
malgré le bruit dans tout ce monde oui
monsieur le fond
qu'est ce que vous faites en ce moment
bien joué même des notes sur jean-paul
ça qu'est ce que tu fais tu le mets
dessus je fais des études de dessin je
peux par les arts décoratifs votre école
de dessin est loin du café le roquet non
à l'état de para les dragons est alors
pourquoi venez vous au café
il n'y a pas d'autres lieux pour ça et à
l'académie je suis n'y a pas de de staël
ou en bus travailler entre temps entre
les halles de pau mais il ya des
bibliothèques n'ont pas dit oui mais je
ne suis pas une étudiante et j'ai très
difficile pour moi parce que je devrai
du sud étudiant justement et j'ai que ça
en somme comme ressource mais pourquoi
ne rentrez-vous pas chez vous alors le
midi comme travailler parce que c'est
encore un gros problème je suis en
banlieue et je ne peux pas rentrer parce
que je n'ai que deux heures entre mes
cours à midi
et tous les midis vous venez travailler
35 à fait oui presse et les gens qui
sont autour de vous n'essayez pas de
vous parler ne vous dérange pas vous
connaissez des gens qu'ils
démissionneraient vous les trouvez ici
non je suis là je peux travailler parce
que vous ne connaissez personne absence
de lieu de travail manque de place dans
les bibliothèques éloignement du
domicile
ce sont là des problèmes que rencontrent
fréquemment les étudiants le café ne
peut en être la solution
mais rendons nous maintenant au souffle
au le souffle au qui rejoint les grandes
traditions du procope ici comme autant
de voltaire on parle littérature
philosophie politique
la faculté de droit est ainsi entouré
d'un certain nombre de petits cafés où
l'on s'agite beaucoup à droite à gauche
on discute ferme mais un étudiant en
droit
n'est-il pas à l'homme politique en
puissance
je fais du droit première année de droit
et 2e année de souffle pourquoi deuxième
année de soufflot un oui parce que j'ai
redoublé ma première année ça fait de
l'insomnie et roccat et donc je crois
pas je vous propose soit le café
directement évidemment j'y passe un
certain nombre d'heures au café mais je
ne crois pas que ce soit la raison de
mon échec en examen vous avez toujours
habité paris oui toujours habité paris
comment avez vous découvert alors je
souffre l'eau
d'abord j'ai découvert parce qu'il est
prêt la faculté et nous pouvons vivre
dans la petite chambre de bonne
je suis obligé de sortir de chez moi et
ainsi je suis amené j'étais amené à
fréquenter le souffle au là j'ai fait
des connaissances d'amis sur le plan
politique
j'ai senti tout de suite une certaine
coloration politique qui existait avant
mon arrivée et c'est à ce moment-là que
j'ai
j'ai fréquenté le plus en plus
régulièrement le souffle mais cette
couleur politique elle était amenée oslo
par les patrons déroulée devant le
monument par les patrons les patrons la
matière qu'on preuve de neutralité
absolue mais il n'ignore pas évidemment
notre pensée politique parce qu'elle est
visible nous laissons nos journaux nous
laissons nos livres et ainsi de suite
lors des manifestations tout d'un coup
le souffle au et plein de mai après les
villes parce que tout le monde n'est pas
retirée manifestation une demi heure
après ils se retrouvent remplie comme
par hasard
tout le monde est rentré de la
manifestation tout le monde écoute la
radio pour connaître les résultats et la
répercussion de notre manifestation et
c'est évidemment disent ils est ce qu'il
ya des cafés où vous n'iriez pas un oui
très certainement revoir du café le
droit d'abord même voire extrême droite
évidemment je serai pas ne serait pas
possible d'aller on sait qu a fait don à
écouter leurs conversations
si l'on crée une cafétéria l'intérieur
notre équité 3 est ce que vous iriez
évidemment je prendrai peut-être un café
mais ce n'aurait pas le même rôle que le
souffle aux quarts évidemment
on le rencontrait que les étudiants en
droit
or il est souhaitable que les étudiants
et une endroit connaissent d'autres
étudiants en sciences en lettres que
j'ai fait une licence de sciences et
maintenant je fais un troisième cycle
physique parce que j'aime au souffle
aussi rencontré des gens qui font du
droit avec qui on peut discuter refaire
le monde en un sens oui ma parole
ce sont toujours des gens du même milieu
que vous que le board milieu où ils sont
toujours des étudiants vous ne cherchez
pas les gens les cafés ou
your aider les gens dans notre milieu et
les employés les ouvriers je ne crois
pas qu'en allant dans un café où il y
aurait des ouvriers je pourrais rentrer
en contact avec les yeux brillaient je
crois qu'il faut il faut beaucoup plus
de contacts avec eux quel contact d'un
café pour vous rentrez dans leur domaine
c'est uniquement le côté politique alors
qui vous attire soufflot le côté
politique
oui mais aussi le côté culturel le soir
lorsqu'on a envie de sortir
on passe au souffle au comme ça et on
voit les copains qu'on peut emmener au
cinéma ou au théâtre parce que je n'aime
pas beaucoup sentir les deux seuls le
soir c'est évident et ça fait fonctions
un peu d'argent que de touristes
le spectacle c'est aussi un lieu où l'on
peut vous joindre
oui a fait ça dans nos chambres nous
avons vu un an par téléphone et nous
avons besoin de passer des
communications téléphoniques et aussi
surtout d'en recevoir
or nous avons besoin d'avoir un local
fixe pour recevoir des communications
téléphoniques mais aussi le garçon café
vous avez vous avertirons lui la des
messages se taira même des mots mêmes de
l'argent c'est vraiment eu un deuxième
deuxième appartement en quelque sorte et
ça ça correspond à un système absolument
signer c'est absolument vital on ne
pourrait pas se passer d'avoir un café
au quartier latin proche de la faculté
proche de nos organismes politiques et
syndicaux l'unef ces terroristes est
selon vous le café dont indispensable à
la vie des étudiants ou sa réponse
absolument indispensable il faut que
l'étudiant puisse se fixer en alu
maintenant peut-être pourrait-on trouver
un autre lieu de ses étudiants mais
en l'occurrence il n'y a que le café
tour à tour lieu de détente de
récréation salle de travail ou scène
politique centre d'échangés culturels
les cafés du quartier latin sont le
refuge des étudiants de paris i
s'échappant de leur école de leurs
facultés se retrouve entre copains et au
milieu de ce spectacle permanent espère
un jour ou l'autre une rencontre avec la
vie
[Musique]